he's spoken with uh with Don Hoffman a
few times yes uh in his bookcase against
reality yeah many more than a few
there's a lot of fun ones because
everyone was Sam was involved Sam and I
interviewed him yeah sorry most of the
conversations I've had with him are
private they're not public but we used
to meet before the pandemic we were
meeting about monthly
to discuss ideas I would love to be a
fly in the wall of those discussions but
he wrote a book case against reality
yeah makes the case that our perception
is completely detached from objective
reality
can you explain his perspective and let
us know well no no maybe not fully but
to which degree you
agree and don't so this is much more
focused I guess you guys have an
agreement that Consciousness is somehow
fundamental yeah I mean I think we both
think we might be wrong
um about the Consciousness they're about
right about it being fundamental but I
think we're both just we both agree that
this is a legitimate
um question to ask at this point in
science is consciousness fundamental and
I really see it as a question and I
think he does too but he goes hard on
reality yes
I you know
especially so I actually now have
recorded three conversations with him
for this project I'm working on yeah and
in every conversation we have we seem to
land on the same place but this last
conversation we had it seemed to be even
more clear that
the semantics really get in the way when
you get into the weeds in these
conversations
we it's almost like we need some new
terminology because it's hard to know
sometimes whether we're talking about
the same thing
um I have issues with his terminology
that
when we talk about what his terminology
represents it seems like we completely
agree but the conclusions you don't
it's possible we have a very similar
view of the universe if Consciousness is
fundamental it may be an identical view
it's hard for me to know because I
disagree with a lot of his terminology
okay but our four-dimens reality he says
that's like a complete
construct space-time is a complete weird
construction that yeah well I mean the
truth is that I mean if you talk to a
neuroscientist like Anil Seth and I
would say most neuroscientists but he's
he's really good on this subject and and
his
um expertise and his area of focus is in
perception so he talks a lot about how
our perceptions give us an experience of
the world and he calls it a control to
hallucination
um I'm sorry he probably got I think he
says that he got that term from someone
else but that's the that's the term he
used we've got every term from somewhere
right that's true everything there's no
new ideas all right
there's a sense in which what Hoffman is
saying is already we already know to be
the case so our brains are creating this
conscious experience
um based on these interactions with the
outside world it is in some sense all a
controlled hallucination
and someone like Anil Sessa from the
neuroscientific point of view I actually
have a quote here somewhere if you if
you have any interest in hearing the
quote
um but he's essentially saying
everything we experience as a perception
including our experience of time and
space so we still don't really know what
our experience of space represents out
there in the world and then of course
when you talk to physicists about the
different interpretations of quantum
mechanics I mean where physics is is
seems to be headed across the board at
this point is that space and time are
emergent that they're not part of the
fundamental fabric of reality and so
there are some ways in which
Dawn is saying things that is he being
too poetic about it is that is that the
right way to to phrase it because like
no go ahead he says like
it's not that our perception is a con
just a controlled hallucination well no
it's not he's saying something more than
that more than that's true I mean but my
point is that a lot of what he's already
saying on some level we kind of science
is already there and could agree with
yeah but not all the way yeah because
he's saying like well that we don't even
we've like The evolutionary process yeah
has constructed our brain mechanisms in
such a way that we're really far from
having access to
objective reality although I think we
already know that as well I mean if any
version of string theory is correct and
you know of course we don't know yet
it's all up for grams but the truth is
each theory is more weirder than the
last
um
if there are 15 dimensions of space we
are just not
we're not wired but to be able to
understand the fundamental reality right
but but I think we have a consistent
abstraction that seems to be reliable
yeah like uh like a blockchain yes and
he's not just saying that we really only
have this tiny window onto reality he's
saying that that window onto reality is
giving us a lot of false information
yeah it's not just an abstraction it's
false yeah because he's saying there's
no reason he needs to be true
like there's no
uh it does it's not required to be true
yeah and in fact there's through natural
selection it's very possible to uh
imagine or it's likely to imagine that
organisms will evolve in such a way that
you're going to just be lying to
yourself completely and but the question
there is if that's the case it's a
really interesting thing to think about
I think yeah the regular which he
approaches it is really
um admirable I mean I do think it's
scientific uh but
it's uh the question for me is why is it
so consistent across all of these
organisms we all seem to see the table
like and feel and so what he will agree
so what I would say to that and when I
post this to him I really don't want to
speak for him but I'll I'll answer it
myself and say that I believe he agrees
with what I'm about to say which is that
the things we perceive
are connected to the structure of
reality it's just that the structure of
reality is made of something completely
different than the thing we're
experiencing
so imagine if you just go with the the
holographic principle
um you know Loosely uh and actually the
holographic principle applies to black
holes only um so there's ads CFT Duality
anti-decider space and conformal field
Theory am I getting all these terms
right
but I can't believe we're going there
well I mean this is where I've gone in
all of my conferences this is this
because the idea is so so if we just if
we just have the basic principle that
reality and all the information can be
contained or is is actually in a
two-dimensional space that gets
projected this is something that you
don't buy based on the look on your face
no no no I'm I'm actually freaking out
because yes any theory of modern physics
gives inkling that reality is very weird
right and completely different from how
we experience that's one example which
is so so this is an intuition that for
whatever reason has has always felt true
to me this is this is the way I thought
about things as a child I've met other
people that felt this way when I've had
experiences in psychedelics and this is
where I start to sound crazy too
nope but um everybody else is crazy
except it does but
that has always seemed right to me and
that's always the thing that I feel like
I'm looking for that it's funny recently
I was thinking that it's it's as if I
feel like I'm and it was more how I was
thinking of how I felt as a child but
um I feel this way a lot as an adult too
that the uh the image is one of a snow
globe that I that I that I'm confined to
the snow globe based on my human
perceptions and the truth of reality is
is out there and it's actually why I'm
so drawn to shaking intuitions I feel
like every time we shake up an intuition
it's like an opportunity to leave the
snow globe for for a moment
um you know it's like smashing the
marbles and seeing Oh it's not liquid in
there like I thought it's it's it's
getting this glimpse of something truer
than what we typically experience
I feel like it's so it's for a long time
going to be snow globes inside snow
globes inside snow globes but the larger
point is that yes whatever is true about
the fundamental nature of reality is not
something we're experiencing however it
is linked and give us gives us Clues to
it so so one image I've been I came up
with recently I actually wrote about
this I have an article in Nautilus about
time
um because I was as I spend time
thinking about what it would mean for
Consciousness to be fundamental
um and at the same time I'm talking to
physicists about
different interpretations of quantum
mechanics and the and and the fact that
the ones I'm talking to believe that
space and time are are emergent and are
not part of the fundamental story
um I was thinking about what is it
what could time be if it's not the way
we experience it what could it be
pointing to
um and you know I'm not the first person
to think like this many people have have
um you know developed different thought
experiments around this but
um and this is I'm not saying this is
the way things are but this is just one
solution is that time and causality
um appear to us the way they do because
for whatever reason we're only
perceiving one moment at a time
and
these connections between events that we
perceive as time are actually just part
of the fabric of reality there's some
structure to
reality at a deeper level
um where you know it's like shining a
flashlight on the structure of reality
where for us for whatever reason
everything else disappears and the only
thing that exists is is
that single pin pinprick of light that
we happen to be inhabiting or that we
can perceive but that the rest of it is
there and so that even though time would
be an illusion and and the causality in
the way we experience it is an illusion
um or it doesn't mean what we think it
means it's still pointing to a deeper
structure there's something that it
corresponds to in the fundamental nature
of reality and I've had many enough
conversations with Don I think
to know that he
he would agree with that that our
perceptions
map onto something
it's just not
the experience of it that we're having
so so to go back to
um you uh the idea that all of reality
could be
contained in two dimensions and there's
something about the the interaction
between different points
um that cause this
holograph so that it seems like there's
a three-dimensional world when in fact
that it's it's a projection of this
two-dimensional surface
um
what we experience as space
still
references something
at the fundamental level it's just that
it's not space
and that is something that makes a lot
of sense to me I also I posted an
excerpt George Messer wrote a great book
y action at a distance spooky action at
a distance
um and he talks about he's he's a great
science writer and he talks about
ways to kind of absorb what this would
mean this ads CFT Duality and he talks
about he gives an example of
um music as an analogy that two
different notes can exist in three
dimensions as if the other doesn't exist
because of the frequency of the sound
waves and that in another way you can
think of the sound waves existing in
different dimensions
I don't know if that's I I I yeah that's
really interesting so I don't speak as
well as I write so
I've written about this in a way that I
think is is easier to absorb than the
way I just described it but I think
causality is a trickier trickiest one
trickier one time there's a trick you
want to like yeah
oh boy and there are physicists who
think that space is emergent but time is
still fundamental and Lee smolen is one
of those scientists and it's really
interesting to talk to him about this
but yeah but time being emergent
um is a really trip you want to think
about yeah also I I wonder if it's
possible at which point does the
experience of time
start becoming a part of the conscious
experience of living organisms so is it
something that evolved on Earth yeah
only or is it also very hard to think
about Consciousness without time
and that's something that's really
interesting for me to think about too
um although not that this is scientific
evidence of anything but I and many
others have had the experience a
Timeless spaceless experience
um in certain states of meditation and
on under the internet conscious
experience would you say yeah absolutely
but didn't you say that some aspect of
conscious experience is memory it seems
like that too no no so I I said an
experience of being a self is due to
memory
um it seems that Consciousness and time
are inextricably linked but I I think
that may be an illusion also and when I
think about Consciousness being
fundamental and you know someone oops
someone like Max tegmark I don't know
who if there are other mathematicians
I'm sure there are he's the only one I
know of who will talk about
mathematical forms and shapes as not
just being he talks about them as being
actual
objects in nature that that exist that
are not just mathematical structures
that we can think about
um but any mathematical structure that
comes out of the math actually exists in
reality yeah and so when I think about
Consciousness being fundamental
I think about
physics and Mathematics being a
description of the structure of it
and that when mathematicians say things
like that or physicists say things like
that
um it makes sense
if we're talking about
a conscious experience of some sort yeah
that's really interesting I mean first
of all Max is great as
man this is really interesting to think
about like how
what is fundamental yeah it's a good
exercise to do in general yeah like that
to truly think through it I mean
ultimately it's a very humbling process
because we're probably in the very early
days of uh well we can't no currently
right right
me I mean maybe permanently but
I I remain optimistic